and they're smart show do you think you
could do it though do you look at it and
go I could [ __ ] do that these idiots
I could do that well yeah I played I
lived in the woods all my life
practically where'd you live again not
Georgia Alabama yeah so you can't have
my life Alabama the rest was in Chicago
you can start a fire right away I guess
I could start a fire how would you do it
if you didn't have a lighter if you
didn't have a lighter I you would be
prepared okay first off you would be
prepared if you ever found yourself
unprepared then you're in trouble
and you kiss yeah it's still possible
you know it's still possible with
friction and if you have cord take your
shoelaces off you tie the little thing
on the thing with this the stick and you
rub it and you rub it until friction
happens and you we have dry good stuff
you know from bark or something under a
cedar or some kind of underbrush that's
dry hopefully it's not raining yeah big
trouble yeah and even with that you can
still find stuff I would love to see a
show called camping with Rooker you just
out there with other idiot celebrities
but you know you know how to survive
could you imagine you're out there with
me trying to show me how to do [ __ ]
Merle Dixon was that was like my home
away from home character Merle Dixon
could do anything in the woods survive
find food whatever he needed to do
shelter of some kind and that's kind of
basically what I could do you can do
those things I can do it now it's funny
you bring up that I was gonna bring this
up but it was all over the place and I
know you but but you're go ahead it's
all about being prepared so you go back
tomorrow cause you're talking and he
would survive Brian loves this hero's
posts everywhere Twitter Instagram
everything it said Merle the Rosen
borough didn't come back or whatever AMC
is cheap
great and you loved it that was grueling
she were they of course they were cheap
come on give me a break
are you serious nobody got any money
those first three four seasons and you
busted your ass we killed it dude we
worked our asses off and we made that
series okay but nobody got any money
I mean we got paid really basics basic
salaries but of course you know the show
becomes popular and then now you know
they start paying people after that but
I don't blame them I do the same thing
why would I want to pay top dollar on a
show that's not proven and you know and
and if I could get really good actors
to do this for less money go for it
after it becomes you know that's my
producer brain thinking never become a
bona fide hit aren't you thinking you
know I deserve a little more money now
yeah of course you do in the end they do
they get more money now right but you
you better not the beginning ones right
not the new guys Manorama and all those
guys get plenty money right yeah yeah
yeah but you work under it they deserve
it dude everybody gets hurt on that show
you know yeah we're running through
woods jumping over logs dodge on what
was hiding rattlesnakes I mean come on
you haven't heard everything